hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast but
Monday July 9th 2017 what's going on how
are ya how's it going Oh Billy's voice
is coming back it's coming back you know
I've been drinking my old throat coati
there right then having some [ __ ]
halls mentholyptus um you know just you
know trying not to yell at people in
traffic trying to meditate trying to
learn about patience oh that guy cut me
off oh if I get upset that's my fault
according to the [ __ ] meditation guy
on headspace he tries to chuckle through
blaming me for other people's [ __ ] us
that's a challenge that's a challenge to
try to remain focused you know what kind
of a [ __ ] guy you know is just
sitting there trying to get into a zone
is telling you that things are your
fault I know he chuckles along I know
he's probably right why why should I
have expectations when I'm on the
highways of LA that somebody isn't going
to pass me doing 90 on the right while
somebody in the left lanes doing 135 and
I'm in the middle likely you know and
I'm in the middle I'm the victim I'm the
guy driving perfectly I never pass
people on the right ball yeah every once
in a while I do I try to be cognizant I
don't even know what I have so much [ __ ]
to talk about I mean I always talk but I
mean I actually have [ __ ] to talk about
by the way shout out to that [ __ ]
lunatic who listened to my whole [ __ ]
give the oilmen the Sun and he took it
seriously like he's trying to debunk my
theory you know just give the shot uh
well all did you think about these
already like [ __ ] 3.4 billion cars
out there
we do both good least that's the way I
read it that's the way you sounded in my
head and I just wrote a back was like
dude how many f-bombs did I drop during
the presentation of that theory why are
you acting like you went to a TED talk
was I like the one person you felt
smarter than on the internet it's like
oh here's my opportunity to be like oh
you're [ __ ] it's the classic internet
the way you dive into a debate oh maybe
try this next time everybody coming at
you like they have like these like just
a bunch of awards up on the wall behind
him you know as opposed to you you know
whatever you what he got it did what
what hacky [ __ ] posters do you have
on your wall huh what's a hacky poster
for the Millennials when I was growing
up you had to have the Farrah Fawcett
poster I know a Fonzie poster or some
[ __ ] like that it was you know it's a 70
when I was still into posters I don't
talk about you know I'm doing is I'm
talking to you guys I'm trying to get
[ __ ] comfortable this guy being couch
we bought one of these [ __ ] pullout
couches and case we have guess what once
every three years someone's going to
stop by here for Thanksgiving
this is [ __ ] Weiss had enough with
them so instead I got to be on this
thing that's not a couch and not a bed
oh it looks fluffy oh it looks
comfortable but the looks are deceiving
so anyways I I've been back in the
writers room I'm back in the writers
room for emphasis family we're knocking
out a episode one we got our first table
read on Thursday and then I'm actually
gonna have to do a couple table reads
over the phone because I got some acting
work in New York City and spoiler alert
they're rebooting Sex in the City
except this time they're doing it with
guys and guess who gets to play Samantha
I don't know what's Cynthia Nixon
whoever the redhead is I'm going to wear
a short little wig alright and I'm going
to be the smart girl of the fellas
that's what's going to happen it's kind
of like that John Travolta movie hogs
whatever the [ __ ] it was called where
they rode around on motorcycles you know
I hate that those movies are hits it
just reminds me of the sadness that most
people live in that they can relate to
that movie like oh wouldn't it be
awesome if we could still go out and do
fun stuff I don't know why you can't I
don't know why my voice still cracks it
49 years of age I don't know why you
can't why can't you continue to do fun
[ __ ] two reasons
one you're exaggerating your importance
as a parent you know what I mean
that's the most important role you live
I know I know it's important but the
fact that you think you've got to
[ __ ] be there 24/7 staring at your
kid and you can't just sneak down the
street you know for [ __ ] 90 minutes
during the day like some what the [ __ ]
is going to happen to your kid knows not
how fragile a mindset is your family in
that god forbid you go down the street
for 90 minutes you know figure 20 minute
drive 20 minute back you got a shower
after whatever the [ __ ] you do right you
go to your rock climbing then one of
those rock climbing gyms you know you
take your talc out your little towel
fanny pack whatever the [ __ ] it is you
do you know and in your head you're
going up mount efforts because that's
all you got that's all you got you can't
go all the way over there and [ __ ]
walk by dead people with sleeping bags
while you had a family a family baggies
you can't do that right you can't
[ __ ] do that you got to go down the
[ __ ] rock wall okay people either
over exaggerate the importance of being
a goddamn parent or they [ __ ] in they're
afraid of their wife
just say look I need to go do this I'll
be back in 90 minutes just and then just
go do it what is she gonna do tackle you
on the way to your car the worst she can
do is just be well the worst she can do
is divorce you and take all your [ __ ]
you know who's kidding who whatever you
know what I mean
you got to every once in a while Wow
like [ __ ] every two three days you
can't just go down the street and just
[ __ ] do something I'm saying this
because I have a tremendous amount of
guilt because I came home from work
right and you know I make sure I don't
work as much as I did last year before I
became a parent because I became the
most important person in the world to
for me so I I come home like a couple
hours earlier than I did last year right
so I can take my daughter for a walk
around the block looking on the wall
right that's what I do okay so the other
day I'm driving to work
no one Jordan work I drop my car off to
get serviced right I got the old truck
I'm driving now I can either go right to
[ __ ] work or and be like 10-15
minutes early or I can swing by my house
and hang with my daughter who just woke
up so obviously no [ __ ] brainer I do
that I hang out with that for ten
minutes I have a great [ __ ] time and
then I leave and I Drive to work feeling
like a great dad feeling great that I
did that I got my priorities straight
right I'm going to raise a great citizen
for this wonderful land that everybody
else is jealous of that's why they don't
like us around the world it has nothing
to do with our foreign policy I'm so
sick of that excuse okay
just admit it do you like our blue jeans
you like that we feed cows to other cows
right you like that you know you like it
you're over there in Europe you're in
Asia wherever you're all [ __ ] jammed
up everybody [ __ ] driving cars on cow
paths or there's like 90,000 skyscrapers
like over in [ __ ] agent Jesus Christ
Hong Kong is the most astounding [ __ ]
be I didn't realize there was that much
concrete in the [ __ ] world
they had clusters of Manhattan skyline
just popped all around that place it was
just never [ __ ] ending I would love
to meet the Donald Trump of Hong Kong
talking about how he has the greatest
skyscraper ever but anyway so I come
home and I'm like all right this is
great I saw 10 minutes this morning I'm
coming on going to get the hang go for
this walk around the block and I walk
into my house all right and I notice
it's hard to open the door I can't open
it all the way and I look around the
corner and what do I see I see like five
giant [ __ ] boxes and then I see an
even bigger box across the room and they
all say Gretsch drums on them my drum
kit arrived
I couldn't [ __ ] it I was so convinced
that I was like Murphy's Law the second
I go to New York for two [ __ ] weeks
that [ __ ] drum kits going to come
there's going to be some nose-picking
jackass delivering it and he's just
going to [ __ ] leave it on the front
porch and some [ __ ] is going to take
it but for once you know life worked out
right I show up it's there it is there I
[Music]
think I've ever been so [ __ ] excited
in my adult life ever so the drum kit
came and it spent literally as far as
when I saw it I don't even think it's
been 12 hours in my house boom right
over to the rehearsal space and unpacked
it and each block she unpacked is a box
with pins in it right you open that box
up and then there's the drum and then
there's this little card this little
card right like a birthday card from
Gretsch drums and it says that great
Gretch sound and it's written in
that writing that Millennials can't read
whatever the [ __ ] you call it we Scout
writing versus printing cursive is what
they call it maybe that's why
Millennials don't like it you know
because you know Kurt I don't want to
Kurt I don't offend anybody I'm going to
print maybe there aren't computers all
day bill and they just don't see it
anymore all right
fair enough whatever maybe just an old
guy bill and you just trashing younger
people because they're younger than you
and they still in the prime ago Hey so I
load up my truck I Drive over the place
about 20 minutes down [ __ ] straight
and I start taking things things out of
the box and they absolutely [ __ ]
gorgeous there's a couple of pieces of
hardware that I need to get but I am
going I'm going to tweet a [ __ ]
picture that thing probably Monday
tomorrow I'm going to go over and pick
up the last couple pieces of hardware
that I need they are [ __ ] gorgeous
and I don't give a [ __ ] what you like
those looks like your [ __ ] I don't
give a [ __ ] what you think of the color
I love them I love them so I am just
over the [ __ ] moon I can't [ __ ]
believe carefully the best thing I ever
did is I got rid of that old [ __ ]
Ludwig and went out bought the kit that
I wanted I can't [ __ ] wait to go over
there but now I have this crushing
[ __ ] guilt you know being a dad well
you should be with your daughter right
now it's like I can't not [ __ ]
yelling at myself as I'm driving over
that kid [ __ ] go down in for [ __ ]
90 minutes not even 90 I played for an
hour twenty back twenty oh it's an hour
and 40 [ __ ] minutes oh [ __ ] that's
more that's 100 minutes of teeth so I'm
the worst [ __ ] bad ever what do you
want for me keeps me in a good mood
anyways they came and I'm going over
there today
my drum teacher he's going to [ __ ]
tune them up I got them sound a
halfway-decent but I'm just a comedian
this guy's a pro so these things are
going to sound like [ __ ] I don't know
what they're going to sound
but uh I can't [ __ ] wait I'm so
goddamn excited and I got school
she's my stomachs growling here I got a
[ __ ] I got my symbols I got the whole
[ __ ] thing but you know how nice this
is how nice the setup is I'm afraid to
show it to my wife
[Music]
that's how nice it is you know that [ __ ]
you know when you do something like that
and then your wife just looks at it and
she's just kind of quiet doesn't say
anything just this is all they do these
go huh any leg out [ __ ] how much did
that humming that noise right there how
much is that going to cost me you know
all I did was buy a set of drums you
know there's bare [ __ ] [ __ ] what's
she going to go get well I thought this
would be fair maybe I'm just paranoid so
anyways I want to thank the Gretch drum
company for [ __ ] making the greatest
goddamn drums I've ever the most
beautiful [ __ ] drums I've ever seen
in my life and packing them up so there
wasn't and it wasn't even even a piece
of dust honorable absolutely gorgeous
and I'm going to go over there today and
I'm going to play because I'm doing a
god damn Comedy Jam the [ __ ] two or
three year anniversary I've lost track
at this point I think it's a two year
anniversary when did it started fourteen
or fifteen maybe fourteen No started in
15 the two year anniversary and I'm
going to be singing one song even though
I can't sing and then I'm going to be
sitting in on drums for the Encore and
know I am not bringing my kid over I'm
not bringing it over because uh I don't
have any cases plus I would be [ __ ]
losing my mind that something bad was
going to happen to them so that's it all
right so there you go that's what I have
to look forward to anyways so what do I
don't know what a [ __ ] start here see
if I can keep my happiness in my drum
kit as I talk about this next thing I
saw - the most [ __ ] up things as far
as just that have you no shame you know
and I'm a piece of [ __ ] so for me to
think that you know
I was watching uh some [ __ ] clip
thrashing dr. Phil and I never saw this
I didn't realize I guess like a year ago
or two years ago you know that actress
Shelley Duvall who crushed it in the
shining she's in her 60s now and I guess
she's having I don't know what she's
having she's having some sort of mental
issue I don't know what it is okay
but she's old and she needs medical help
that scumbag dr. Phil who I called it
the second I saw that guy I called it I
I think I was like that guy looks like a
[ __ ] crooked cop the second I saw him
I was like that guy's looks like he
planned a [ __ ] gun on you you know he
[ __ ] shoot you over some routine
[ __ ] traffic stop and he'd pull it
and he'd do that to a white person
that's how [ __ ] nuts this guy is
right he's not your standard you know
bad cop going after minorities this guy
would do it because I Cassie is a serial
killer look doesn't he anyways that
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] interviewed
Shelley Duvall and talked to her as if
he was trying to help her and she was
saying all of this stuff about how Robin
Williams was still alive and [ __ ] you
know the earth is flat just all kinds of
stuff like that words clearly like oh my
god all right shut off the camera shut
up the cameras come on let's not do this
to her and he's sitting there talking to
her a lot so like he's going to try to
help her so like you play that Robin
Williams is still alive okay I think you
need like he was acting the entire
[ __ ] time like he was trying to help
her rather than completely exploiting
this famous actress who's now in like
you know this mental condition it just
follows famous I don't I don't how to
Pete how do you still sit down and watch
that guy's [ __ ] show [ __ ] that guy
and everything he's [ __ ] connected to
Jesus you don't have enough [ __ ]
money yet [ __ ]
you don't drag enough [ __ ] penniless
people onto your [ __ ] show you have
enough honey booboo people coming on
your [ __ ] show you got to do that
jesus [ __ ] christ but you know I've
been meditating and what I guess I'm not
supposed to get upset about this I
should have you know I should expect it
I should expect that behavior out of him
so you're saying that you're hearing
these voices in your head or saying I
I'm making up all of this [ __ ] I
couldn't I couldn't get I don't think I
got 20 seconds 30 seconds into it the
second she said the Robin Williams sing
and then they cut to him though as your
saw and once he did that I had to just
like shut it off shut it off shut it off
dr. Phil have you no shame
I swear to god that [ __ ] guy I'm
trying to think what he wouldn't
interview you know what wouldn't he like
first of all I love that people watch
those shows as if they're like watching
somebody trying to help somebody they're
not you can't fix somebody in a
half-hour episode on that time when he
had that girl on that little girl on
there the you know catch me I said my
dad that one that went [ __ ] viral and
then he has her back on again he's like
people thought I was exploiting her so
we took out the studio audience yeah but
you still broadcasted it I don't know
but you know something I'm a
hypocritical [ __ ] all right because I
still watched the catch me outside how
about that I just kept seeing it on
Twitter and I was like I have to see
what that is and I'm not going to lie to
you I did watch it and I did enjoy it so
maybe I got to knock back my criticisms
criticism why don't you just exploit
people that still have their whole life
ahead of them jesus [ __ ] christ I
don't know did I become the [ __ ] by
the end
I don't know where the [ __ ] that whole
thing went so anyways I was watching the
f1 race in Austria which by the way
there's something [ __ ] crazy going on
in Austria right now Jewish people relax
it's not that well it kind of is it's
kind of related to that then you know
you know in [ __ ] in England like all
this [ __ ] is old because that you know
that's the origins of white people
unless you listen to an Aussie album and
somehow we all came from Egypt which
they're not really black either are they
they're like Arab you know what I mean
but he's like yeah they're African it's
like all right well I'm German and Irish
do I also claim to be Italian because
I'm European like African at Africa is a
continent I've never been able to so
you're saying that we all came from
Egypt hey right now there's no [ __ ]
way I did if you ever saw my [ __ ]
legs yeah I mean I don't know how
[ __ ] long ago my ancestors left
Africa and then why we did what we sat
in a [ __ ] snow Jacuzzi for [ __ ]
2000 years I don't know but I do
actually I do believe that we all came
we had to all come from the same [ __ ]
whatever lake do you know what you
realize what you're listening to right
now you're listening to a comedian
trying to figure out like just because
he watched like 10 minutes of Neil
deGrasse Tyson whatever [ __ ] name is
as he's falling asleep and if I can
quote deGrasse Tyson whatever the [ __ ]
his first name is I believe he thinks we
came from trees and I don't mean like we
were living in trees like we were Apes
he's like no trees like I don't
that was one of those things I was just
like fall asleep that's like just some
guy's crazy
I fell asleep I never saw the other
other part of it do you know what the
deal is you go over his house need
convince you of it you go over and eat
have on a turtleneck with a sport coat
over it like smoking a pipe and they be
a fire in the fireplace right he'd come
in and you have all these [ __ ]
artifacts get out you and your wife show
up to these other couples there and
you're just thinking like this guy's
either going to [ __ ] tell me the
secrets of the world or I'm going to
slowly lose consciousness and end up in
one of those silence of the lamp it's
trying to steal his dog anyways the [ __ ]
am I talking about I oh yes I'm what
happened in Austria so what's happened
in Austria it might already been solved
I just never seen it a little while ago
because a couple weeks ago I was trying
to see where the f1 circuit was taking
him next and I guess in Austria Hitler's
house still exists like where he was
born but it's more like an apartment
building so I guess all these neo-nazis
go there and they do like the neo-nazi
like Yolo selfie you know instead of
doing the peace sign
I bet this it but that you can't do like
a full Sieg Heil
you know in a selfie that's a hard your
arms aren't long enough to hold it out
so they probably do it to the side you
know when it's just from the elbow to
the tip and then they do the duck face
right I guess they've been doing that I
don't know what the [ __ ] they're doing
they're doing some [ __ ] like that in
front of it and for some reason people
feel that if you take that place down
that you know those guys aren't going to
continue to exist I don't know about
that what I mean what do people you know
I was going to be a neo-nazi but done
they dig it took down Hitler's [ __ ]
building so whatever so there's somebody
that owns it he's like now I'm not
they [ __ ] down and the government's like
right again [ __ ] save it right that's
how they talk in Austria - everybody
talks like my bad
sort of [ __ ] English accent maybe
when I want the [ __ ] is Davy Jones
whatever I'm doing so there's some big
battle about that they're going to like
knock it down but I got to be honest
with you as much as I'm not down with
the Nazis like if I went to Austria I
would go see that place I would be like
the most evil baby and you know the
Jordan of evil babies you know [ __ ]
came home to that place right there
people walked in and saw baby Hitler and
were like oh isn't he adorable look at
his eyes there's a lot going on in there
so they want to get rid of that I know I
thought that that was [ __ ]
interesting like this is what kills me
like who [ __ ] how do people know that
that's what he grew up so many people
[ __ ] died in World War two you think
that anybody that even remotely [ __ ]
remembered it the old people dark I
really grew up that place right down the
street
oh we have funny look on his face I
never liked them right they just passed
the story on it's too juicy a gossip
that it just does Logan Hitler's it just
keeps getting passed down to the point
they got a knock down this perfectly
good [ __ ] building I guess I need to
be redone a little bit like we're doing
with the baseball stadiums over here and
then what happens they throw it out and
ends up in the ocean throw it out in the
[ __ ] Mediterranean Sea that water you
know the water that when you go over
there they try to say there's no sharks
in them until you go on the Internet is
that go yeah I just saw there was a
couple of attacks Miami I mean there's
been a couple of attacks but you know
that you know that's it's rare
yeah shark attacks in general a rare
considering most of us are on the
[ __ ] land I don't know I swam in the
Mediterranean I absolutely loved it it
was [ __ ] life-changing but afterwards
when I was reading about the shark
attacks there is just this [ __ ] it's
the scariest thing other than being
tortured you know I'm trying to think
you know stuff equal to that speaking of
shark attacks I was watching this
[ __ ] movie that starred Paul Walker
rest in peace Jessica Alba uh Scott Caan
this other woman her name escapes me her
name escapes me I was watching that
movie and I don't what the [ __ ] it's
called I always [ __ ] : Jessica Alba
first of all is so [ __ ] beautiful he
just looks like she doesn't he just sits
there she looks [ __ ] amazing Greg and
that movie was so [ __ ] ridiculous
yet entertaining I don't think I've ever
seen people hold their breath longer
underwater in my life you know there's a
[ __ ] crash plane under the water they
go down there they find drugs this is
even like a spoiler alert this is like
how many [ __ ] times they've done the
movie where regular people find a bag of
money or they find some [ __ ] drugs or
would you we do I knew we should leave
it no we should take it man this is a
shot right and then the [ __ ] bad guys
figured out that they [ __ ] took it
somehow right the same classic [ __ ]
story right then Tom Hanks lost his wife
and he meets meg Ryan in Seattle it's
all the same [ __ ] movie Billy Crystal
comes in and says a couple of things
okay then Rob Reiner makes a cameo
because he's directing the thing and
then somebody starts shooting up Tom
Cruise runs through and the dubs come up
and there's your [ __ ] movie it's
every Hollywood movie somebody's getting
too old for this [ __ ]
the two people that hate each other
realized that they they now love each
other the two foes then look at each
other and they realize that you know
what I respect you
you know the Days of Thunder ending I
think that covers it right anyway so
we'll watch this [ __ ] movie and at
one point the bad guys have scuba gear
Paul Walker and [ __ ] Scott Caan have
no scuba gear they just dived out of his
[ __ ] plane but delayed like 20
[ __ ] feet under the water so they
[ __ ] the scuba guys swimming to the
plane looking for him Scott Caan is
sitting in one of the copilot seat
pretending to be dead he had enough time
to sit there gather himself pretend to
be dead holding his [ __ ] breath and
the scuba guy comes up and looks at him
he's like well I guess you dead and he
keeps going and meanwhile they keep
cutting the Paul Walker rest in peace
right
he keeps [ __ ] peeking in one of the
windows and the scene is like five
[ __ ] minutes long real time it feels
when you just do in the math how long it
would take to get down there how long
you can [ __ ] stay down there and he's
like peeking and then he would just duck
back out of the way and all they had the
decency to do is have like one or two
little air bubbles go like if I'm
underwater and I don't have any [ __ ]
air I mean your heart's already racing
like a [ __ ] lunatics are heating up
that oxygen forget about the fact that
there's these drug dealers with scuba
gear that want to kill you and you're in
shark-infested [ __ ] waters didn't
affect Paul Walker or Scott Caan in the
least somehow they were able to throw
effective punches under the water I mean
it was it was unbelievable the leaps of
faith that you had to make in that movie
yet I still enjoyed it you know because
every time you were like this is [ __ ]
ridiculous they would cut to Jessica
Alba just going like should we keep the
drugs or something you go oh my gosh
[ __ ] beautiful genius the editing of
that movie is genius I don't know what
it's called though dude she has one
scene she just leans against the door
brushing her teeth it's like I could
watch a movie of that Jessica Alba gets
ready for bed so check it I think that's
what that movie is it's called something
something about they always called the D
The Cove I don't know what it was but I
was just sitting there you know in my
own way making fun of the movie trying
to make me a laugh this is like jazz
gonna I'm not gonna where is your
ethnicity you gonna wear a shirt which
is probably childish that's what I do
here wait a second I got to find out the
other name of that actress on that movie
a name three of the four stars right can
I hang on a second
actually you know what [ __ ] that I'm
going to look that up I have to give
somebody I gotta give two people a
shout-out I've been watching bloodline
I'm up to Episode eight season three I
got two more episodes to go that show
that series is gut-wrenching like I can
only watch two of them and then I have
to shut it off and I've never watched
the show where I get so mad at the
characters you know I guess so [ __ ]
mad like why the [ __ ] did you just do
that shut up stop talking all of that
stuff most of its with the Kevin
character Norbert Leo Butz one of like
five people who ever won the Best Lead
male Tony Award that which is a Broadway
Oscar basically the amazing [ __ ]
actor so anyways there's a guy on that
show who plays Eric O'Bannon who's
absolutely killing it
his name is Jamie McShane and for
Breaking Bad fans if you're wondering
how do I know that guy's face why would
his face [ __ ] make one of my how do I
know that guy if you're Breaking Bad fan
the episode I'm not going to give
anything away the one that involved the
Train all right I can't remember he
played the conductor or the engineer and
he was a great [ __ ] guy and his work
on this show is [ __ ] unbelievable I
don't know I want to quote his lines but
I want everybody like
when they watch movies it's like years
later you know my dad just saw like I
did this movie called stand up guys and
he calls me up he's like Christ oh yeah
I tell you the other night I'm sitting
down I'm like I'm like narcoleptic I'm
falling asleep on the couch you wake up
at 3 in the morning and I'm watching
this movie and I'm already laughing
because I know it's gonna be some [ __ ] I
did like [ __ ] 10 years ago
because it's got ALPA Chino and
Christopher Walken and I'm watching the
movie and all of a sudden there you are
I'm like oh he's [ __ ] he wakes up my
mother go Jesus Christ oh that's all my
parents pay attention to my career they
watch [ __ ] that I did because it was a
great movie
I'll tell you Phil you know you could do
this comedy stuff you can do the
dramatic [ __ ] a [ __ ] got it all
figured out that's the season you can do
the dramatic [ __ ] it's my favorite thing
anybody's said to me all week you can do
the dramatic [ __ ]
so anyways two thumbs up from my dad for
the [ __ ] stand-up guys check it out
if you get a chance
anyways Jamie McShane is [ __ ]
everybody's killing her on that show and
then also John Leguizamo I mean that guy
ever been bad and anything he's [ __ ]
everything he's in he makes it better
the guys [ __ ] unreal and he's like
creepy and hilarious all at the same
time which I don't know how you do that
unless you're a [ __ ] genius like that
guy this is seen how do I do I want to
[ __ ] ruin it for people he goes in
any orders like what we used to call
like a Slurpee or a frosty you and I
want to see orders one of those it's one
of the funniest [ __ ] scenes I've seen
in a long time you start watching
bloodline and I'm telling you if you
want to not have your insides get
[ __ ] all twisted up just you do two
episodes at a time okay the first season
you know it's like guy you know it
starts a little slow like most series do
because they got to establish who the
characters are with the background
but once that [ __ ] rock starts
rolling down the hill so I'm going to
watch the last two episodes today and
and I don't know you know I'm excited to
see what happens but then I also have
that D like I almost had the balls to
say this I almost had the nerve to say
like you know when you're finishing a
great book like I read I remember back
in the day when I used to read and a
book would end and I used to read a lot
of that was that guy who did all the
Trainspotting and marabou stork
nightmare books I used to read all his
[ __ ]
Irvin Welsh or something then I started
reading the classics I remember I read
the full version of the Three Musketeers
cat is the count amount of Christo it
was like 700 something pages of the
smallest [ __ ] typeset or font you've
ever seen in life and I'm like I'm
finishing this [ __ ] thing I'm
finishing this [ __ ] thing and I just
would try to read like 20 pages a day it
took me months to finish that [ __ ]
book and but I did I finished it and I
was like wow not like I spent a
significant part of my life reading this
book that's how much how slow I read and
all these years I was always proud that
I read that book I read it like 20 years
ago and I remember thinking like you
know this is what people did back then
they had time to read books like this
because there wasn't the internet there
wasn't the TV and all that and they were
bored and needed to be entertained so
these guys would just spin these yarns
that would go for six seven eight nine
hundred [ __ ] pages and recently I
forget where I saw it they said that
Alexander Dumas however you say his name
was getting paid by the word and then 20
years later I'm like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you could have finished that [ __ ] like
200 pages I read like the director's cut
of recount amount of Cristal I still
love the book gotta love a story or a
revenge you know
so anyways this is the time when I would
usually read some [ __ ] advertising
but um I'm doing this early because I
got [ __ ] to do tomorrow I got [ __ ] to do
tomorrow man
I got stuff to pick up the last few
pieces of hardware that I need for my
kit and then I'm good to go there let's
see let's see let's see the advertising
has not come in yet so what do I do now
- I just pause here and I just pretend
like I have reads to do how many minutes
have I done 37 37 minutes you know I'm
just gonna continue talking about the
[ __ ] I want - then I'll just - I'll just
hit pause and when the advertising comes
in I'll read it and then when the
[ __ ] the questions comes in I'll
[ __ ] read those - so anyways well so
what you're saying is I saw this thing
you know when I shut off the f1 race
which is it's kind of becoming my teaser
here like people you talk about it are
you going to talk about it when I shut
it off okay but I'll talk about the f1
race congratulations - uh I want to say
Valerie Valtteri whatever his [ __ ]
name is botas he had such a good start
to start that race they actually thought
he was a [ __ ] cheetah like the
Indianapolis Colts there and it was a
typical [ __ ] f1 race where was the
first guy to turn one won the [ __ ]
race there was a [ __ ] accident in the
beginning right the guy in the [ __ ]
the stepchild of the Red Bull team that
were that Rojas [ __ ] team whatever
the [ __ ] - whatever they are Jesus Bill
Graham yeah Almanack grabbed a [ __ ]
program if you got to talk about it have
a little bit of respect for the people
that actually watched the goddamn race
what's the name of their [ __ ] team
what is it what is it where all the Toro
Rosso Rosa that [ __ ] lunatic he came
in and he [ __ ] slammed into one of
the McLaren's who then slammed into the
the Red Bull guy
max Verstappen and every one of them the
whole [ __ ] day was over that was it
it was over Botox was out in front
lewis hamilton got like a five position
I don't know penalty because he had
changes gearbox during qualifying so
even if he was number one the best he
could have done was in qualifying was
six so he was started eighth so I guess
evidently Wade over you yeah Faisal yeah
yes I guess he came in third anyways
pretty uneventful race the whole [ __ ]
time other than been in the end it got
great it got great but I you know my
actually loved the [ __ ] that Lewis
Hamilton was talking they were talking
about the whole is his [ __ ] with uh
what's what's his face they're Sebastian
Vettel and he goes he goes you know what
he plan to do it goes you know I'll go
out there I'll try to exploit a few of
his weaknesses just floats that out
there so of course the report of bites
and goes what are some of his weaknesses
would you say his temper is is one of
his weaknesses because I guess this guy
a Vettel is he's dangerously approaching
twelve penalty points to get twelve
penalty points you have to sit out a
race within a calendar year that
basically points for being a [ __ ]
driving dangerously slamming your car in
the Lewis Hamilton whatever the [ __ ] it
is he still would he's like those people
on the highway out here that passed you
on the right there with ninety he does
[ __ ] like that so if you accrue twelve
of those points within a calendar year
you have to sit out a race which is
devastating especially if the guy you're
going up against wins the race it gets
25 points he's just sitting there on
your ass you know sitting on your helmet
so anyways they said he goes I'm gonna
exploit a few of his weaknesses so the
reporter bites and goes this is temper
one of them and Louis smiles it goes yes
which is the perfect thing you want to
do with someone with the temper you know
speaking from experience because all
that does this make us more mad and then
we [ __ ] up again right so then the the
reporter goes
well what's his other weakness and Louis
just smiles he goes he's like I'll keep
that one in my pocket and he walked away
and I was like I that was perfect
perfect he did but anyways like I said
it was pretty uneventful for the whole
time
everybody was cruising around the
[ __ ] track no big crashes after that
turn one and I'm the [ __ ] American
team the Haas team was up front for like
two left you know they gave us a little
pat on the head like we've all able to
hold up the Ferraris for the first three
laps of a 71 lap race and as an American
I'm supposed to be excited by that is we
have the Ferrari jr. engine whatever the
[ __ ] they give us so anyways the the
final like six laps Rick Lewis Hamilton
was right on [ __ ] Ricardo's ass the
tires are all [ __ ] chewed up I was
convinced Hamilton was going to catch
him Ricardo was able to hold off hold
them off and then Sebastian Vettel was
right on both tosses asked once again no
passes were made but it was still
[ __ ] exciting the last six laps the
race was great and that track was
[ __ ] cool as hell then I love how it
starts like up hills that bizarre I
don't understand a track laid out like
that and it's in the the Austrian Alps
how do you not [ __ ] go to that swing
by Hitler's house you go to the f1 race
and then you get yourself in viña
schnitzel how do you not how do you not
do that [ __ ] trifecta
that's a bucket-list thing right there
before they tear it down I mean I was
always a fan of the omen always all
those horror movies those demon babies
how do you not [ __ ] go there and just
be like you [ __ ] learned how to walk
in that house it's just fascinating like
the first time he lost his temper was in
that house
first time you realize together he could
draw I don't know how long you [ __ ]
stayed there it's just eerie you know
what I mean
look if Universal Studios if you can
take the tour over there and they still
have the [ __ ] the psycho house you
know does everyone just wants to look at
that this is a real-life [ __ ] psycho
it shouldn't be glorifying I'm not
glorifying it the same reason why I want
to let's see a great white shark from a
boat you know I don't [ __ ] this is so
as much as everybody [ __ ] [ __ ]
there's no way if you walk down the
street you could you couldn't [ __ ]
look at it you couldn't feel that that
[ __ ] vibe of evil coming off the side
of the [ __ ] house Wow they probably
right they should block your tear the
[ __ ] thing down you know I why am i
talking about Hitler's house can
somebody explain it to me so anyways the
race ends I shut it off a coming in to
go do the podcast and I ended up as when
I shut off the race this is woman was
short hair you know she's got the
[ __ ] the his same haircut is that one
loser girl I'm coming after you better
get the party started
I'm gonna bourbon remember that pink
right had the pink haircut and she
sitting there talking to this guy and
I'm looking at it like this looks like a
[ __ ] therapy session what's going on
here and the show was called the
therapist and they then am and she
sitting there it's Katy Perry talking
about herself and like you know some
people like me some people's own
something I like my hair my hair but
they don't like the shower haircut and
I'm just sitting there thinking why are
you doing this sweetheart you should do
this in private
why would you put all these [ __ ] out of
it is she going nuts
but as much you know her I felt bad for
cuz it's just like she's [ __ ]
obviously going through some [ __ ] but
Dec the [ __ ] therapist guy they got
this whole intro and he's like walking
through doors and [ __ ] like I'm saying
saying I'm a licensed [ __ ] therapist
you're a [ __ ] money-grubbing pun
acting like you trying to help Katy
Perry had to shut it off I had to shut
it off I rewound it because I had to
find the name of the [ __ ] show and
then I had to [ __ ] walk away Jesus
Christ Katy Perry if you need therapy go
to a [ __ ] therapist close the [ __ ]
door have her shut up her phone and get
it out and I hope you get better you
don't [ __ ] do it on TV do you realize
what you're doing you're letting the
world know what hurts you and you're on
the Internet
you want to your [ __ ] mind these are
my weaknesses and every [ __ ] [ __ ]
on the internet is going to be coming
after you it's a bad move that is not a
good move in like that licensed
therapist air-quote [ __ ] that guy
that guy should be disbarred but you
would you [ __ ] exploit something like
that but you know what the end of the
day I mean was probably her people's
idea she greenlit it and then they had
to find they had to find a therapist low
enough on the rung with enough TV
presence that would [ __ ] agree to do
that gig I'm trying to think of this
stand-up equivalent to that a televised
you know what it would be it'd be like
those [ __ ] gigs that Beyonce and all
those guys do for like [ __ ] new years
they go out they sneak out of the
country and they go do like [ __ ] and
they sing bootylicious for like 5
million bucks to the son of a [ __ ]
dictator you know in some country that
we're at odds with I guess like that's
the TV version of it maybe I don't know
who the [ __ ] knows
speaking of all that [ __ ] did you see
when Trump went to Russia and in bed
flick and Vladimir Putin you see that
that was [ __ ] hilarious you know what
that's when they [ __ ] with shooting
this [ __ ] it
reminded me and Jimmy the gent and
after.look the Swans ahyes over the [ __ ]
you said when Trump walked in Putin
should have been like Khmer yo come here
yo less wanza left
how do you say Lu f th Lufthansa heist
modal I don't [ __ ] know anyways oh by
the way rest in peace great drama passed
away about four years ago Jonathan
Blackwell who absolutely killed it with
prince new power generation played on
Justin Timberlake's big I think his
first album that tour was it blood sugar
sex Magik he never would sexy back to
her stomping on a disco ball whatever
the [ __ ] it was called I can't you know
I actually own the album - that's the
sceptic WAMP WAMP WAMP wham bam bam now
BAM now I'm bringing sexy back bear
right what's that other one then I
always get the words wrong and they
always laugh what is that one oh I
always think he says dirty [ __ ] I'll
let you with me in this behave I would
say he's gone dirty [ __ ] they always
laughs going he's not saying dirty [ __ ]
nice I go what's he saying she goes a
dirty babe or something like that you
know is the hardest one to [ __ ]
understand is that Rihanna she's got the
accent and she doesn't uh she says like
the first three letters of every word at
the end of a sentence which what's her
new [ __ ] hit you know me and Mia well
[ __ ] forget what the [ __ ] we were going
but we had on like pop radio right
little pop stations there is that what
it's called top 40 it was hilarious like
they played the same 10 songs on the way
there and the same 10 songs on the way
back
then they lack lag lag lag lag i wasn't
that one but it was the same thing at
began with a w what i was gonna [ __ ]
drive me nuts
I gotta look it up all right Katy
[ __ ] Perry Katy Perry what a show
Katy paid not Katy Perry sorry not looks
Kwanzaa not Jimmy the gent Rihanna
Rihanna music see if it comes up
umbrella ella ella eh eh oh oh e e come
on loading slowly loading i'm running i
ship to talk about I might have to
[ __ ] hit pause there at this point
and that can look up the song oh yeah
they defecate a web live luck no it's
not that one she's a lot of W songs
don't stop the music work love on the
brain Diamonds umbrella we found love
[ __ ] better have my money okay man down
alright is that I'm just I'm too [ __ ]
old to be looking at this [ __ ] you know
what I mean god bless you god bless your
hits okay I'm gonna [ __ ] I'd like
being an old guy and you know something
when you're [ __ ] old guy you got to
know when you're too old to be [ __ ]
looking at something you just walk away
you know like those [ __ ] I don't
understand why guys over 40's take those
[ __ ] testosterone pills it's like you
finally clear in your head you know what
I mean you finally getting out of the
[ __ ] bars you're finally really
realizing how much more sustained
happiness you can get out of order and a
brand new drum kit and set in the
[ __ ] thing up then the [ __ ]
colossal waste of time that chasing
[ __ ] is you know you see the question
you're a guy over 40 try was it eugenics
they act like your testosterone dipping
is a bad thing it's a [ __ ] great
thing the clouds are finally party why
would you want to take a bottle of that
be 18 for every [ __ ] juice Jesus
Christ you want to go back into the
sports bar shorten up the [ __ ] sporty
slash horror-themed waitresses right the
original Spice Girls as they walk around
with jerseys tied on living the gang
wants to win my buffalo wings this
slowly [ __ ] killing you why would you
want to take a [ __ ] pill that's going
to make you think that that's a good
option I'm going to go back into that
you know then you got to start p90x then
you got on a Myrtle right a man girdle
trying to suck in your [ __ ] you know
guys the torso just starts it just keeps
getting sicker and sicker right she got
you [ __ ] you still get your skinny high
school legs can just boozing it up you
got that goddamn beer belly
now you're going to [ __ ] throw some
18-year old [ __ ] testosterone down
your throat is you're walking up there
you know you got to dye your goatee
before you go down there what the
[ __ ] you're doing let it go man [ __ ]
it
Jesus Christ I will never [ __ ]
understand that I want to go back into
that [ __ ] world granted I experienced
it with an orange afro I mean maybe you
guys had a better time that I did I
don't [ __ ] know I don't pretend to
know anyways I think this is it I don't
I can go any [ __ ] further here if I
talked about everything that I wanted to
talk about I believe I have Oh coming up
this weekend me and Dean Del Ray host of
the let there be talk podcast are going
to be at the fountain Street Church in
Grand Rapids Michigan this is one of my
favorite [ __ ] places to play it's a
still functioning nondenominational
church
all right which is why they let
comedians go in there if I ever decide
to get back into religion I think I
could you know what I bet I couldn't go
to nondenomination one either because
they'd be so busy patting themselves in
the back about how open-minded they are
just whatever you want to do do you want
to stand you want to deal and I have a
let Catholic in me going there's got to
be some sort of structure what is the
[ __ ] drum circle anyways we're doing
two shows Friday I think one Saturday or
the other way around all I know is the
third the third show has just been added
there's still some tickets left they
they've just added that thing because
the first did so well so thank you to
everybody that's showing up I can't wait
to go up there and run my [ __ ] mouth
standing on an altar you got to go to
this if you don't see me you have to see
a show at this place just to see the
[ __ ] venue that it has an upper deck
horseshoe upper deck that one's from one
side of the altar right down the hall
all down down the side of the [ __ ]
you know the windows there to the back
of the church and then comes right back
up again like a horseshoe right like
what they still call Ohio State Stadium
even though they enclosed it and like
the altar is like the new stands that
they stuck in there when they enclosed
it so I'll be up there and then I go to
New York to do the acting gig I'm just
basically filibustering right now see if
I can get the [ __ ] that ain't coming
in god damn it they're not coming in I
want to read some dates for you you know
not like you can't do this on your own
bill burr calm stand-up dates I have got
to change the [ __ ] picture oh I got
one with the shaved head
I just never [ __ ] I got to learn how
to upload photos alright where do I go
here shows alright this is what I got
coming up then I got in August 10th Red
Bank New Jersey Count Basie Theatre all
right and then after that one August
13th all things comedy producing
their first stand-up special ever
Paul virzi all right me and Pete
Davidson are going to come out on stage
and get the crowd warmed up and then
Paul's going to go out and absolutely
crush it it's taken place it's going
down at the Tarrytown Theater in
Tarrytown New York absolutely beautiful
bring the wife bring the kids don't
bring the kids come up there hang out
with us watch a great special tickets
going fast
I'm sorry August 10 11 them in Red Bank
Oh in 12th
oh [ __ ] and then I [ __ ] hang up with
virzi BAM on the 13th August 27th
Hyannis Massachusetts at the Cape Cod
melody can't Joad then I'm doing the
Hampton Beach casino first show sold out
that's on the 30th second show they out
of the late show September 2nd I'm in
Valley Center Harrah's Resort in
Southern California in September 8th I'm
at the Horseshoe Casino in Blues Ville
Mississippi Blues Ville Mississippi and
then I'm going to an Alabama game
Crimson Tide all right going to that
September 22nd I'm at the Toronto the
Sony Center the Sony Centre in Toronto
Ontario in the 22nd 23rd
denim in Vegas on the 29th then on the
6th of October I'm in st. Petersburg
Florida that a man my happy theater now
this is what's great about that gig is
the Thursday I'm going to see the
Patriots play the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
that's the last NFL team I need to see a
home game of including the [ __ ] Los
Angeles charges but I'll go to one of
those in September then I do my gig and
then the next day I go see that Florida
LSU game and on December 14th I got the
hard walk and in Florida and I might
have an overseas gig in Europe
in December in my favorite city over
there my favorite city did take my wife
possibly we're working on it we are
working on it I'm going to hit pause
right now I'm going to wait for the
advertising to come through I'm going to
read the [ __ ] but it's not going to
take any time out of your life because
I'm not doing like you know not just
going to leave a recording you know what
I mean all right I'll see in a couple
hours but in your world to be a couple
seconds all right I'm back goddamnit I'm
back and I have advertising to rate ok
Pro [ __ ] flower Pro flowers were they
were advertising for what's coming up
talk about the reaction you got when you
surprise the recipient with ProFlowers
bouquet you know what nobody you know I
think [ __ ] go you know what I got the
flowers that was so thoughtful you know
what it is everybody that I know that I
send flowers I send them to him so I
don't get to see the reaction you know I
guess start setting this myself
you know then you put them behind your
back and you just Pat you take them out
then you get to see the surprise
predictability is boring says ProFlowers
surprises are exciting says ProFlowers
ProFlowers makes it easy for you to
surprise someone right [ __ ] now and
it's making it even easier with a
special offer for my listeners and
whoever else they advertise with send
ProFlowers farmstand flowers and get 20%
off of this collection or any other
unique exclusive bouquets of 29 dollars
or more proflowers.com makes choosing
the perfect surprise bouquet simple and
quick
flowers are guaranteed to stay fresh for
at least 7 days or your money back you
can get the flowers last longer than
your feelings for the person flowers are
guaranteed to stay fresh for at least 7
days although you get to pick the exact
date you were expected to surprise your
surprise will arrive flowers give you
more bloom for your buck Pro flowers
those big beautiful flowers with more
stems for your money to get 20% off the
first
[ __ ] flower or any other bouquet of $29
or more go to proflowers.com and use my
code bar at checkout
that's proflowers.com and code ber be
you are are don't wait to make someone's
day oh go ahead and be unpredictable
your goofy selfie all right
oh but o me on DS me on DS gave me some
long-stem roses Bhutto told me undies me
undies I'll recycle it and give it to
Joe two roses he's got free eyes and big
[ __ ] glasses he goes to the bar he got
no classes Joe DeRosa wears me undies
that's why he's got that goofy smile
cause it ain't soft what's the what's
the first thing you put on the last
thing you take off its your underwear
that's what you do not your socks you're
[ __ ] weirdo make your most important
piece of clothing the best it can be
with me undies what is me undies you may
be asking yourself at your cubicle or
possibly your glass office huh as you
stare at all those people that work for
you uh starts filling up a little bit do
you feel powerful all just seriously
soft feel good underneath delivered
right to your front door my undies are
designed in LA and made from sustainably
sauce micro mode al modal a fabric three
times softer than cotton the undies
softer than soft lugs on these luxurious
what does lu x evening luxurious
underwear come in an ever-changing
selection of classic colors to dress
your dick in bold shades and adventurous
patterns so you can tailor your balls
tell your undies to your own personal
style and guess what you can save time
and money each month with a monthly
subscription monthly subscription how
much do you [ __ ] yourself and if you're
not ready for a subscription that's okay
you can still save that's because me
undies is offering you 20% off your
first pair just use our special URL me
undies com / / and 20% off your first
pair I never realized how perfect a
monthly subscription is if you suffer
from anal leakage if you eat those
Doritos that don't make you fat and some
I'll give you ABS
the one side effect is anal leakage
remember that [ __ ] you know who is that
what Brandon to read with the Doritos I
don't know what it was I think the
flavor was cool mist or something this
is perfect you get a subscription
immunity so go ahead revamp your
underwear drawer let your ass weak you
deserve it once again that's me honey
calm / Burundi's calm / / Oh Dollar
Shave Club Charlie Sheen Club is the
smarter choice you get a great shave a
great price conveniently delivered right
to your [ __ ] front door
you no longer have to schlep to the
store Jesus Christ buy a cheap
disposable razors staying behind some
[ __ ] old lady trying to develop
pictures from a camera no one's even
seen before
or you can just join up Dollar Shave
Club and when you use the Dollar Shave
Club executive razor with the cab is
easy shape of the blade gently glides
across giving you a smooth shave dr.
carver shea butter is transparent just
like your relationships for a more
precise shave helps prevent ingrown
hairs and fights razor bumps right there
white guys all the way to black guys
ingrown hairs - razor bumps make the
smile joy by joining Dollar Shave Club
and if elected I still will joy Dollar
Shave Club for a limited time new
members to get their first month of the
executive rings with a tube of it you
can for only five dollars with free
shipping
after that raises just few bucks mom
[ __ ] you're in the clear that's a 15
dollar value for only 5 bucks there are
no hidden fees and no commitments cancel
anytime you like you can only get this
exclusive offer at Dollar Shave Club com
/ / that's dollarshaveclub.com / /
upside everybody upside down boy you
turn me inside out ramp all right upside
your [ __ ] turn to me there's a better
way for you to buy business travel it's
upside calm up sad calm every time you
buy a trip at up side you'll say
company a ton of money and they give you
an amazon gift card worth hundreds of
dollars
upside at Epps eyes able to do this
because they bundle your flights and
hotel together and just picture flying
with chickens and hold one low price
bundling prices save money saves monies
if you're a frequent flyer business
travel your company saves a ton of money
and you get thousands of gift thousands
a year in gift cards don't you when
you're a frequent flyer and all those
other cont line up and you got to walk
around them like they're trying to draw
an offensive foul but for whatever
reason they're facing the basket you
want to give them a floor room Shebaa if
you're a frequent flyer business travel
your company saves a ton of money and
you can get thousands a year in gift
cards just for buying your air and hotel
together at UPS add calm [ __ ] turn me
plus you still get your all your miles
if you're shopping for business travel
you'd be crazy not to check out upside
calm up sad dock it takes just three
minutes to see how much you say by
buying a flight we get it it's [ __ ]
amazing right now
when you use my name Barbie you are are
you're guaranteed to get at least a $100
Amazon gift card for your first trip
that's my name BER to get at least $100
Amazon gift card for free save big on
travel and get a gift big gift card
every trip I love upside comm you know I
just like saying the name upside calm
your turn at me minimum purchase
required see the site for complete
details oh look who's here our old
friends lastly but not leastly stamps
calm stamp saves you time and money
which you can use to grow your business
I could mail any letter any package use
just my computer and printer and the
mailman comes to picks it up for the
hassle of the post office mail
everything from postcards to envelopes
the packages domestic or international
create your stamps calm account and
minutes online with no equipment to
lease and no long term commitments click
print mail and you're done
don't need to lease an expensive postage
meter I use dance calm because because
they [ __ ] pay me to say it now
anytime I have posters and I'm going to
[ __ ] myself afterwards and sell on my
cell is animal food stamps calm I'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] if I can figure it out so
can you and right now you too can enjoy
stamp stop calm service with a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus postage and a digital scale without
a long-term commitment go to stamps.com
click on the microphone top of the home
page type in bur that stamps comm enter
ber stands calm never good as opposed to
out this again alright we're done the
question all right
Norway when are you coming to Norway man
we would love it man when we need it
before we end to end up like Sweden have
a nice weekend and go [ __ ] yourself
though he's trash and sweet and yet
people want to know when I'm going to
come to Norway oh is it
Mia plus one there you go little baby
boo bear there here you go you can't sit
in that chair right there
you didn't even entertain that option
alright upside down you're turning me
give in love bin stink to bleep okay
round in I was talking about deep into
the blue ocean with Jessica Alba and
Paul walk up into the blue into the blue
into the blue alpha hello blue that
racist ass moving oh [ __ ] racist yes I
was a racist I watched it as a white
person I have a problem with any of it
surprise surprise what did you see no
that's mean where they have young talk
into the mic for the love of Christ you
know what people have tweeted me and
have been like we can hear you just fine
well then they would say that I was too
[ __ ] loud I mean yeah what they
happen they're used to it by now
alright I'm talking to the microphone no
there was this one so this plays this
movie takes place in the Bahamas right
but of course you know there's like
barely any black people in it
and it's white people on vacation
they're not on vacation they live and
work except for Scott if your albums not
white oh right oh [ __ ] now who's not
being racially sensitive
yeah she's young okay fine she's not
white but they're in the Bahamas that's
where black people live anyway can I
just telling you how I you know anyway
one of the guys that either works for
them or works with them in some capacity
he has like maybe two lines and one of
them is I got to go my baby mama is
hassling me over a weave or like needs
me to give her money for a week anyways
well it needs a new weave like what the
[ __ ]
they were capturing the here you know no
no thanks I give him a line and hit any
kind of like a dignity like oh I gotta
go I told my wife I'd watch the baby or
oh I gotta go my son has a soccer game
my baby mama needs a weave that is so
racist that is so event and then there's
another scene where there's somehow
explaining I don't know pirates or some
kind of Bahamian legend that you know
Paul Walker is explaining and then
what's his name Scott Caan is looking at
pictures and he's like I love Scott Caan
there's a Snoop Dogg here and these are
all his hold it is his pimp cup fella
but it's like really he used to be in a
rap group he knows the terminology you
know what it was the 8-mile that was
based on him it was based on mmm and I'm
not even worldwide Scott Caan in a rap
group like I'm just not even know what I
don't really want to talk about that got
econ Scotty Cohn
oh that's it did he stretch to that
right he came out oh my yeah me Roger
let me Rocky's got it goes ridiculous
the one unbelievable you one thing that
I liked about that movie I can't believe
we actually watched the whole thing but
there was a scene I enjoyed it it would
show where it Scott Caan and Paul Walker
are talking about the life what are we
going to do man and then underwater
holding their breath of the
they're above country they're on land
and it's daytime as they're talking and
the camera slowly pans around them like
really slow and by the time it's done
The Sun has said and it was a really
beautiful shot other than that that
movie can go kick rocks right oh that's
good you hold the baby kick rocks and
kick Ross he said the f-word in front of
her real trying not to do that
I mean but that movie was ridiculous and
I really upset up that line it still
bothers me I gotta go my baby mama needs
a new one we need wait they were under
water for 15 minutes like I can suspend
my disbelief on that that wasn't
something that I'm just saying I mean if
they're going to handle wine making
excuses for this that line and I'm
moving because I'm why are you mad
because I meditate now and what I've
learned is doing I'm learning to have
patience patience with was with just
people's behavior well you're lucky that
you have that ability to do that I was
very offended and annoyed by that no I'm
just saying that like if there is a view
in that line not to me I'm white well
I'm not asking about you as a wife I'm
just asking it went over my head did it
then I'm just saying I didn't get it I'm
telling you what it is but why are you
sitting you're acting brand-new like you
don't understand what I'm talking about
yeah yeah I'm just trying to be at some
point no honey well I don't care about
it being funny I know it's a ridiculous
[ __ ] line but I got to keep the
comedy going this is in California : 0.1
0.1 into that point/counterpoint you got
a more in for a host yeah keep the funny
for the love of God please let's not
lose the funny
god forbid you actually agree with me
come on [ __ ] and try not being on you
pitch this episode to dear white people
for me good lord I got it it's [ __ ]
offensive I'm agreeing with you I'm
trying to [ __ ] keep it funny on some
level
fine I'm trying to I'm just playing the
ignorant white guy you don't have to
play at anything
Nia I'm the one who said the line first
I was laying there I go I got to get my
baby mama we've terrible it's terrible
writing being holy what the [ __ ] is
offensive it's [ __ ] people jumping
over there walking around all naked look
at good holding their breath
four hours do you honestly think that
they're going to have Maya Angelou or
one of those people and then [ __ ]
heads that the right reference sure
alright what else you get I don't know
okay Norway when are you on this by the
way you know stupid is when I was
imitating Jessica Avila doing live
selling and Haley she's dumb she's got a
billion dollar [ __ ] company where do
I get off saying that huh although my
podcast is doing pretty well
going iTunes alright Norway when you
come into Norway man we love it we would
love it and we need it before we end up
like Sweden have a nice weekend and go
[ __ ] yourself now you mean travel you
know what that means now but before we
end up like Sweden yeah you know what
that mean I don't know you don't
remember they said Sweden Sweden used to
you know Sweden remained neutral during
World War two okay okay and they look
the other way and they allowed the Nazis
to use their train system to go into
Norway and [ __ ] Norway up is that what's
going to happen no okay Norway had right
before the war we gained the lower third
of their comfort country from Sweden it
seems like whatever we didn't want it
anyways or whatever right so then they
they're in World War two Sweden remained
neutral okay let the Nazis go through
the Nazis [ __ ] up Norway Sweden became
a power after World War two just simply
for the fact that their cities were
still standing and they could function
function in like a business capacity
changes I'm using some pretty impressive
words for me right so long story short
no way ends up finding and no way didn't
offer anything I mean Sweden offer no
and you're helping and stuff long story
short no end up discovering all this oil
in that land that they got back I
believe or norther that now they making
so much money over there nobody wants to
do like lower-level jobs so Swedes come
in and do the jobs Norwegians don't want
to do you don't remember the Norwegians
saying or the Swedish people saying yeah
we're like the Mexicans for Norwegians
Wow okay you don't member that no I
don't remember that at all when would I
have wonder was that when the guy said
it to us we thought it would the
Norwegian guy when we were in Norway I
gotta be honest with you and you're
probably going to jump all over me but
we did Norway Finland and we'd like I
honestly can't I don't know
I don't recall which was which country
because it looks the same you realise
rap you realize well go try to cover
your tracks go try to cover Utrecht do
you realize we've been told me don't
follow a Rwanda [ __ ] on down to
Ecuador and what is the other one over
there
you took me in three African countries
right The Gambia with Gambia Africa
South Africa and then we went to Rwanda
like yeah you know it be honest with you
yeah I know what you saying it's a bunch
of blue-eyed blonde-haired white people
it looked the same Norway Finland and
what was the other one we went to what
was the other one I want to go I let it
go which a plane ticket cost my sweet
and I love cuz I love Stockholm but what
were the other three I don't know why
don't you go get a [ __ ] lobe and spin
it around a couple times
figure it out I can't remember which
country with which I always wanted to
travel the little girl
hey history it was Oslo where we had
that crazy meal that like ten-course
meal like the neverending with the
cheese at the end just I had Norway why
don't we just move out to the alabaster
sand knock on the kardashians door right
now why don't you just do that and just
fit in with them what is anything that
I'm saying how to do with the cards that
plays oh I don't know movie eight could
she you remember what Finland versus
Norway like what we did because they
were geographically very similar all
right I'm gonna have to do I'm going to
remind you of these places in a way that
your little travel brain little travel
can remember okay all right Finland yeah
was where you've got the coat yes okay
okay now you remember that Norway's
where you got the cheese yeah okay great
Stockholm you loved so you remember that
there you go that's the difference okay
yeah so Finland's the coke country got
it ah slows the cheese the me oh yeah
yeah we had that 200 course meal yeah
and then there was that funkiest cheese
ever and I was hating it you were
telling me to stop and my eyes were
watering and happen boy you told me to
stop the more I had to eat it because it
was funny to me alright what's cold
I remember being close yeah
all right Paris was the place that had
the arch like in Washington Square Park
yes I remember Paris alright restaurant
doesn't accept cash dear how dear Billy
red tits restaurant and summary this is
backwards
I said restaurant doesn't accept cash
dear well one word Billy red tits I mean
it's Billy red tits restaurant doesn't
dear really red that's alright the other
day I went to a very trended salade
place in Hollywood and when I went to
what I said I trended a very trendy
salad place in Hollywood and when I went
to pay I held out a $20 bill and the
cashiers said sorry we don't accept cash
that's the most ridiculous thing have
you heard this before yeah I'm like
trains planes and [ __ ] planes I don't
think they do what do you think I mean
are they working towards a cashless
society we're going to be microchipped
and that's going to be it and right when
they gain control of all human society
the robots are going to take over
alright lastly but not leastly the last
question here girlfriend wants me to
call her daddy during sex there's a new
one hey Bill I just started seeing this
girl we've been dating for about two to
three weeks she's not attractive
everybody says this career-driven and
generally speaking has her [ __ ] together
she seems like a girl seems like a girl
she seems like a girl as far as I can
tell she's got all the lady parts that I
could see myself having a long-term
relationship with however recently when
we were having sex she insisted on
calling me daddy I've never been the
type to talk dirty oh oh oh oh I say
okay I get it oh okay I thought it was
the other way around I thought she
wanted you to okay I get okay okay I see
you know all right well that's pretty
pedestrian however recently opened up
but uh I've never been the type to talk
dirty because it seems kind of silly and
takes me out of the moment yeah you guys
are not compatible she's going to a sale
is filthy crazy over-the-top [ __ ] and
you're gonna be like I Oh like in your
[ __ ] Chi whatever the [ __ ] you're
doing
you know which neither one of you were
wrong I don't know if you're compatible
here when she started calling me daddy I
was
caught off guard but tried to play
through it because I didn't want to make
her feel weird well you're a good person
then alright I even attempted to throw
away my own lines like oh yeah you liked
it but afterwards after the words left
my mouth I had to try not to laugh
because it felt like I was in a cheesy
porno and it started to affect my
performance after what she asked me how
I felt about it and I just brushed it
off like it wasn't a problem but on the
inside I was starting to have my doubts
so trying to paint a picture without
giving too much detail because I know
you get all the weirdos you get all
weirded out by [ __ ] but I I don't get
weeded out by a lot of [ __ ] is it weird
that she likes me to call her daddy am i
walking into relationship with
underlying daddy issues help me out bill
what should I do
oh I get to be dr. bill um so weird you
having sex with you oh she wants you to
call her daddy that's how dr. Phil would
handle it well Oh most of my fan base is
females so you're the male and you're
therefore always wrong now I would
definitely bring it up to her I will
bring it up it's difficult to bring up
something like that with somebody but
that bothers you you got to bring it up
I would bring up just say listen I'm not
judging you or anything like that but
for me you guys you got to keep up use
your side of the bed it just feels weird
now how do you say I don't feel
comfortable cook haven't you called me
daddy in bed it just it makes just say
uncomfortable don't say weird
and that ain't Nia I need your help
oh yeah G coming alright this guy this
guy's with this girl he thinks she's
great and everything she wants and she
wants uh him to call she wants to call
him daddy during sex and it weirds him
out
how does he bring it up without making
her feel like she's got a [ __ ]
problem I don't want you to call me
daddy during sex because it makes me
uncomfortable I don't think it's wrong
I'm not judging you but just for me for
me that was perfect
yeah just be honest there you go we just
say I'm not trying to judge you I don't
think you're weird because I know a lot
of people do it because a lot of people
do do it but just I makes me
uncomfortable and I'm not ready to go
there just yet can we come up with
something else what they went different
language like she said Papa yeah you
just pictures some completely random
language I don't know is German random
enough German now you don't go there
next to no she's taking a [ __ ] in your
chest I don't know buddy you got a yeah
however Mia just said it that's perfect
all right I'm gonna wrap up the podcast
here alright that's the podcast
everybody thank you for listening thank
you guys once again for watching f is
for family we got I know you never know
what the [ __ ] ratings you get on Netflix
buddy you know they gave us another
season so there you go I really
appreciate it that's it please come out
and see me and Dean Delray at the
fountain Street Church Grand Rapids
added a third show tickets are hopefully
going fast but hopefully there's some
left so you can get them because I'm
saying this some left alright that's it
I'll talk to you check in on you on
Thursday bye